I'm a boy with shape-shifting arms
they're never the same all the ladies
love me I got a knife and some pucks and
I got a gun with a little bit of bullets
and that's it I'm not packing so hot
oh you're packing no portraits second
yeah he is attractive all right what am
i doing that guns tiny is massive hands
um okay I'm going out this door yeah I
know you can remember that big Bell in
front of the door that she did Jill cook
was too weak to move yes oh that makes a
lot of sense
that is really strong got it people on
Twitter we're recommending that you
start fighting the nemesis when you get
the chance yeah they said that [ __ ] they
said that you get like some sick drops
if if you can damn I mean I knew you did
by kylus you Jukes oh good yeah I I just
thought he was gonna be like first of
all people who follow this I knew sorry
I knew he was gonna be a pain no I
didn't know there was another one um I
knew he was gonna be a pain to [ __ ] kill
but like that fight does not encourage
me to want to fight him because that was
really hard
mm-hmm he was a really difficult fight I
wonder if like just the normal
encounters will be as hard as that if I
were was
all right LaBelle I think was across
like in there well that's the only door
I can go in good choice
oh wow this place is please got recce
rekt probably from that rocket Richie
Rich's Christmas record anyway like with
my current loadout there's no effing way
I could so am I going nose or sis I
think South really that's a spider
arachnids wait what do I do
oh they're [ __ ] Oh
Speights I hate that I like the big ones
are easy to dodge
Santee room
okay so I'm going straight through to
the watchtower oh wait this is the
beginning yeah oh crap don't you want to
go this way off to a good start
back through spider dome can I shoot
them it doesn't seem worth it but I
wonder if they're like the birds or they
can really like you know take you out
okay it's a straight and to the right
straighten to the right so you're going
north I guess I remembered or is I don't
think you know very much of anything no
wait I thought it was in here
oh crap where is it I think you know is
it around this [ __ ]
still fine oh I forgot I forgot welfare
not poisoned forgot forgot forgot that
sorry I'm fine
[Music]
No okay cool this is the Bell
oh I'm so strung I hear your name like a
bell ringing ding ding okay so I'm back
at the tower Oh Hospital hospital first
apart well looks like those are locked
so it looks like it's all Hospice ready
maybe Jill has to go into the park
should I save the barrel nah come back
and then use on all four of them got it
if you're good enough okay
camera angles probably change the yeah
okay okay I think we should reload the
map listen try again that didn't go very
well better by onin block massive
explosions it's far enough away there's
a hospital right there just go start
over come on sure he got eaten so what
are you getting like a cure for the
virus at the hospital that makes sense
are you like while you're there you get
a cure for seventh degree burns damn it
hey I was gonna say that you were close
to it but like last few times I thought
that it didn't do anything I know an
alligator in pressing will - I thought
you had to be like really close to it
like I thought I was safe I was it was
wrong that's all right I was really not
that far know so I don't feel that bad
um feel a little stupid did you try to
like not even acknowledge it when you
opened up and saw danger do you think I
wouldn't see it
I knew I I knew what the damage I had
caused
okay everybody welcome to resident evil
3 here we are starting for the first
time today nothing else has happened yet
it's been pretty boring everyone knows
what happened
Oh big dumb dumb let it go
merry just came in here into the
they're playing she does not picked up a
controller yes today I probably will do
it better hope did it worse no
consequences retreat no surrender I mean
we'll see see how this like I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go this way I went for the
door I went for the door
you can push him off pretty fast yeah
actually he is like he's less likely to
receive damage yeah maybe it's hard to
tell
alright so now I'm in spide zone
[Music]
[ __ ] you but ii spied zone
mama spiders mamacita spies all the
ladies love me sorry girls no time of my
accent oh they love it
can't get enough of that hot Carlos
stuff all right so should I also still
kill the barrel just better yep okay
maybe come into that second camera angle
yeah okay
all these are good good option just
don't blow yourself up I did it
maybe a little too early but the good
news is you did it you make an easy for
kill who I assume will have to come back
through here you're probably right with
a lockpick maybe actually just so we not
only the logic later check that door at
the lock doors I wanna see if they're
like lockpick doors so you know ring
think ahead
oh it's a doctor it's kind of ironic
heal me he needs a minute his own
medicine outcast a lock thing cool bring
that next time why I yeah Jill yeah as
Jill I'm just thinking ahead god I know
I totally got it yeah it could kill him
I was just uh I mean Jill's gonna come
back here you know but I could use one I
can't shoot more than one one one I'd
like a 90% you raise your deal-breaker
number
okay what am i working with okay one
area one door got it anything around
though there's probably health [ __ ] okay
I just wanna show you that so many had
like which floor is a floor would and of
paint and just slapped it right there on
the information sheet because even when
you're bloody typically what's your
floor do I go to for stab wounds yeah
what
what is that why to kill a zombie what
is it
Oh a liqueur is it okay still fine
Carlos you fine will you dodge nice they
die like liquor they're like liquor 2.0
is accept your assault rifle is like a
Saul rifle 2.0
jeez I'm already on 86 but you've got
about like 86 percent left I hope
everybody in the world knows the kind of
person you are from the serious and
unenjoyable loss did you check that
other room for items are you still in
that room yeah I'm in this little bonus
box spicy raccoon do you assume that's
what that says yeah
the spicy reckon you better Japan a few
times the vending machines are huge
should I take these plants yeah I got
room dude
not only are the vending machines huge
in Japan but they are everywhere and
they're super convenient anyway anywhere
you could be like in the middle of like
I don't know some back-alley street the
middle of nowhere and you're like I
could I could go for a coffee and
they'll be like a vending machine there
you can get a really nice coffee here's
my question they have a better system do
you
I was just ignoring everything you're
saying do you can you like share your
stuff with Jill I don't think you can I
put it in the know because we have
different boxes so you're saying I
should have left this plant so I'm
saying if you're only gonna Carlos for a
limited time you should use your healing
when you get a chance okay well I don't
need to because I'm OC do you pick up
that first day it's very serene I wonder
if you're coming back here that's your
thing I don't know you could just this
place might explode Oh true remember
when those places exploded before yeah
cuz I could leave this now take it
you're probably right
[Music]
I'm just gonna do a once-over on the
table oh nice nice I mean to be honest
with you
[Music]
not yet right yes you really don't know
I mean if you're if you can't you're
only been playing for 15 I know if you
can't share them with Jill you might as
well I know they're giving you somebody
you're in have five I know that's what
makes me upset because if I can't give
those to Jill I'm gonna be pissed
cuz that really it really screws me over
I'm gonna keep the health spray and I'm
gonna move on I don't think I see
anything else
I probably missed something I don't see
anything else
I'm going to progress Carlos no Carlos
Oliviero I could have saved should I
save no I just do it on the way back
boom boom it's just a lot of blood in
this room that's all right there see it
that's not a good sound I have no way to
make bullets like health and saving
isn't the problem it's it's like I'm
running out of ways to kill things here
Oh marijuana speed check those lockers
check that or examine it ever okay hand
get em up nice I really needed that I
just take the knife um I just thought
maybe I want it stabbed a fool cool it's
not a very big Hospital
we should probably say even the way back
though isn't like you're gonna be in
here much longer that's the whole man I
know I kind of like want to save right
now honestly what are you giving a knife
boy wait did you check this entire room
I checked this whole no probably not
we examined the tape recorder quick okay
[Music]
okay so should I listen to it or like
I'm a little confused with what it wants
me to do here like I could don't think
I'm going to that no that's an elevator
so never mind there might be more in the
hospital oh yeah you're right
I think it's an elevator it looks like
doughnuts make you go nuts but it's red
and I don't think I have anything to
open it right okay gotcha should I save
sure
because like the odds that what do you
think sure you have five say Bourbons I
don't think you're gonna be Carlos for
crazy dinos no too sexy now hey I'm just
really confused by the whole thing man
get rid of your knife anyway okay a
knife run in res evil three that'd be
pretty impressive I didn't know you
could even do that you died friend of
most of them I'm gonna get rid of this
blue cuz that doesn't help me I'll keep
everything else
[Music]
yes this was a better run than the
barrel run
mm-hmm I'm already doing much better
okay let's do it now I feel even better
get rid of your name gribbins if you
haven't already paired weren't thinking
[Music]
sweet
I wonder what's through this door funny
if it was just the nemesis no that's not
funny okay
[Music]
hello however that was the password
hated I didn't even listen to his stance
stupidest stands
he's also staring at the wall of it over
there this isn't working
[Music]
elevator activate press the button I
didn't know it
multiple basement first or fourth floor
uh I typically save basements for later
okay I'm open to suggestion but I've
already clicked the button so I'm not
that little think it was going up do you
know if an elevator like cables snaps
and you're in freefall freefall you're
supposed to lay flat on the floor of the
elevator I think that's just one of
those things that people say but they
die they're probably gonna die but it
would disperse the weight more that
wouldn't just like shoot your legs up
through your rectum so avoid that room I
mean you could've shot them probably but
oh no it's doing that thing again
oh don't freeze it's not freezing it's
like taking a really long time to load
[Music]
so what's the [ __ ] is in there
I guess you could just shoot them with
us all right we'll start laying into him
what do you think am i still fine
Oh Carla's alright what do you think
should I use the bullets to say it like
maybe chances are try the other room
first alright so I got to I got one to
the right and one to the left we'll try
the right no wait isn't that the
elevator
[Music]
seems just like more slugs in here wait
that guy got [ __ ] exploded in a car
explosion what's going that guy's super
dead yeah you should be
now that was me Kyle I'm one of the
super this is the dude oh no you're a
red is to do from the gas station wait
did he just get blown through the window
Oh what is going on go check out a lie
[ __ ] you how is his body still I don't
can't like check his body
I'm trying apparently it's just all mush
he doesn't have anything to say this is
soup my friend I was weird totally um
there is not like what's the point of
this room there's like nothing there's
nothing I don't know I don't feel
comfortable like just leaving it like
that but it didn't didn't really feel
like it oh there's this back area
probably should have investigated just
like some kind of jar back here okay all
right I was wrong yeah I don't doesn't
feel like a room I want to give me that
key these are zombies yes I was taking a
photo that close to being eaten
it's a scientist they're like studying
it as they're being eaten yeah okay is
that it okay well I have a key so I
think I need to kill those slug demons
do you think those are baby the things
that we're in the sewer
okra the grave digger maybe
all right made you check that far room
as well that mean
that's the elevator right like I'm
getting confused so that one's red
there's that button do anything but it
could be the sickroom red button do you
think just set dressing this one mm-hmm
nothing all right so slugs yes right
okay or the other room maybe there's
something I'm gonna do slugs okay all
right so should I use my machine gun
probably they're gonna be really hard to
kill they're gonna swarm you a future
handgun all right here we go here we go
okay get off me
all right sick of this [ __ ] this appears
to be the sickroom but I don't think it
is I think that guy was eaten
three two five five three two no don't
do that I'm getting dangerously close to
being full what do you think I'm gonna
take em okay you're probably gonna use
the keys soon anyway
I think so all the ladies love me and
the number is two three five No
all right I think that's it okay
probably didn't need to use my machine
gun they were they would have
[Music]
so what happens of using no you just
like keep all these [ __ ] keys and
your inventory yeah I have been fighting
a cold sure it's not the t-virus
[Music]
looks like you could push that card why
is it telling me that
pressure plates
[Music]
I got it
no I won't love you move it that's
surprising get to push it against the
wall first well you'd think I need to
push it this way right so that I could
push it up did you check it at all from
the front up why could I push it that
way probably just have to line it up
better on the right side
got it stupid Carlos are you gonna put
on the other one just stand on it I
don't know yeah I haven't thought that
through what if the patient figured this
out what would happen I don't know kind
of a weird situation that hospitals even
have secret
[Music]
okay we're supposed to put on the other
one maybe I don't
others for thoughts
could you check when you when it said
something appears open place here right
did you press that check it or I mean it
just kind of says it when you stand over
it
wonderful three to five anything to do
with other numbers on them what do you
say the same thing all right so you need
some pressure plates but where do I get
them were they any other rooms how would
I put them in this room so just like
reset it maybe you push it to the wrong
okay I don't know wait 402 is the room
number I wonder if that matters
Oh 402 plus 325 okay should I try the
other plate
I guess cuz like it zapped me which to
me might mean wrong one right
I don't think based on very little yeah
but way actually come back to this side
of room because that's like that come
like you want why would the front of the
cabinets be up against the wall oh that
makes sense but also like so you want to
try one of these in this [ __ ] [ __ ] the
camera girls do
[Music]
wait hold on one more left or right look
at it one more time like where which one
has better Fung Shui for the room left
[Music]
you're no interior decorator where's
that pic it's a weird little puzzle
isn't it
hey good wait it's like normally it
gives you a [ __ ] gun which it probably
did and we've just missed it maybe but
for me this is just like a crazy amount
of trial and error which I hate
[Music]
yes a weird puzzle
it's a weird hospital 2:35 just getting
three to five
your key oh the TV the TV vixen it's the
actual sickroom this is the fake
sickroom it's not that microwave thing
this is not how hospitals work all right
so I've got the vaccine base bring it
back to Gil oh no I got a basement to go
to so the actual question now is should
I save again but she seems like a waste
maybe not I don't know don't say no who
knows how much longer I'll be with
Carlos I mean I do have a full I got
like two almost two full heels I don't
and I'm blow yourself up again oh my god
I'm sorry the people watching
[Music]
let's kill to the Wi-Fi back
[Music]
[ __ ] I'm on caution she's a green area
buy that right now I hope our let's see
so fine you so fine you blow my money
alright
[Music]
chuckling it's a dead end
[Music]
try to stop using this I feel like
you're gonna fight the nemesis yeah
[Music]
I'm just upset I think come around the
corner I think there was a barrel or
something
[Music]
I can't see
[Music]
I can't see hate everyone
[Music]
show yourself like are they even around
the corner there we go down for the
count
[Music]
caution where are you you idiots if I go
past here they're gonna [ __ ]
[Music]
and hate you I just got my flu vaccine
yesterday I didn't get one this year
that was a mistake we have a an annual
day like it's CBS just the company
gamespot his own by by the way in case
you didn't know and they let you get a
free vaccine and I was so busy I think I
had two live streams that day and I just
didn't go and I I like I've been really
lazy this year about it and now I'm sick
and it's like I'm undoing it it's worth
it
huge come join your brother where is it
oh my god he's hooked what an idiot
I wish I could toss a grenade okay we go
here he comes now you go [ __ ] all
right
bullets are low for Carlo but as long as
I can get the other half of this golden
amulet I'm gonna be okay golden amulet
yeah beakers
what are those things I don't know
they're terrible set-dressing cuz I
really want to shoot them bottles of
various viruses bottles of various
viruses such a casual thing to say yeah
just bottles of casual viruses oh no I
don't know the answer to this I guess
it's like not a puzzle all right so this
could be an important room for Carlos
note on the door it looks like oh god
that symbol doesn't look good that thing
in the thing doesn't look good
shattered glass I'll see you in action
[Music]
alright not a fan of this room
[Music]
right
[Music]
put a hatch in the floor hatch but
you're standing up yes
maybe nemi's gonna attack you here socks
[Music]
obviously he's gonna [ __ ] come out of
there I hate to cultivate a vaccine
follow the procedure supply energy to
the system set this medium base to the
device okay so I need energy to the
system then medium when the device is
ready you can start mixing the vaccine
medium to mix the vaccine you will need
to control the five levers this will
cause the two gages to increase or
decrease oh my god if you adjust the two
gages so that they stop at the center
the vaccine medium will then be produced
automatically
[Music]
okay
all right so base then medium then use
the levers pull the levers this is a
stupid way to make a vaccine all right
so I got to make okay I got to get power
on
[Music]
well
so if you do it wrong are they gonna
come out maybe I don't know read that
thing again
it doesn't say like monsters will appear
supply energy to the system medium base
to the device and then add the vaccine
then control the five levers they will
cause the two gauges to increase or
decrease adjust the gages that they
stopped at the center all right so where
do I apply this base okay
medium base use it all right little [ __ ]
maybe just looking at the wrong part of
the machine
okay
I don't know how to use these gauges
figure it out
this sucks alright only doing below and
that's what one does
so that brought the right down for and
the left one up one
what's operate the synthesizer yeah
let's just do another lever Oh gotcha
okay so I
so if I hit two again does it go the
other way that's my question
oh maybe I don't know cuz like I'm
really confused yeah okay so which one
what did that do it went down for right
oh [ __ ] that's a lot okay there right
when I'm fine three was and the left
went down two okay so that one went up
three and that one went down too
well that would bring it back so now I
should go below and try a or B I don't
know what these are I hate this Oh God
because I bet you if either of these go
too high or too low one of those [ __ ]
comes out it's when I go that's my guess
so that goes down for and the other one
goes up three so do like so I'm gonna
I'm gonna do that backwards right
because I don't want B to make either of
those go over now do three
all right
does that make the right one go down oh
no try one or one one of them makes the
right go down to one an to do if you
press them right now to like reset that
and then try to oh like go backwards oh
man I hate these okay it's there one
that makes one go down three know that
are you sure that recess the opposite a
like brought them left down the right up
we really should be writing these down
yeah that's like literally how you do
this [ __ ] we're really close
now try I'd like to write these down now
try you're just trying random things
take forever do you above
press
do
one
and now
neither of them raises both I know I
know you know but no hold on so you want
to bring the right one up a lot yeah
which will be try one yeah the one will
bring out the right one up a lot yeah
because we just undid it I know I know
I'm just saying but now what the left to
go off the right to go
one is left down one right up for
so if we bring the left down now do one
right
[Music]
what is 3do
oh [ __ ] all right now
now do one no.2 try to
or when it's either to or what it's like
going to be - and one of the leathers I
think just try to and the wanted letters
and then we can restart if it ended
right they're both down pretty low
how do you know the letters restarted
they don't what I'm just saying we can
back out alright well do you know what
okay let me ask you this does a raise
left or right I'm just saying at this
point for every set we might as well
just try it anyway I see what it does no
because I don't want it to go too far
down I think that releases a monster
that's why you should be there's no
point write this down I'll just look it
up if I don't feel like you're being so
bad though because you're not being it
you need to know which one they're
they're going to sew a raises left up to
and right you need to go up which would
be one or two right now which would be
one one lowers left and raises right I
think no oh yeah that's it but it's
point down I can't forget there yeah and
then two raises maybe oh maybe I should
yeah okay this actually now it's one or
two
I just did too
be me just scripts the worst
we're getting closer but I don't know if
we're learning enough
according to what I just looked up
because I don't care to solve this you
only have to press three buttons oh my
god one three a just back out and reset
it I don't feel like solving these for
the purposes of this place she's seven
where's are we are they reset they are
not reset so now we're in danger of
going too far but we can we can
instantly I'll be back with one so I
will another one three and a I don't
know what it started at right but it
doesn't matter what it started out yeah
it does
you wait quit out quit I did
now go turn the power off if you can
oh my god why don't they let you to
reset the whole thing
okay wait I see what you're saying okay
so yeah put it's not gonna matter though
like putting two back to it shouldn't
have mattered at all because they all
raised the same amount and lower the
same amount
yeah but the order matters because if
you'd like lower it start them out with
one and then raise certain amount would
be it's gonna be different than if you
start out so you want to raise the right
side and they want to raise both we want
to raise both which we can't do I don't
know okay
does a preppy cuz just do be if it
didn't do what you wanted to reset it
lasted - I know but I don't feel
comfortable it's I'm just trying to get
as possible if you have to fight someone
that cares okay cool so now go on
is there one that reduces and raises B
is it Chi right try a suit that I think
it's - it does but he's too much
now try one and then two or one of the
letters
and now try one again - its to where it
lowers the right well - lowers when on
but it's it when it's off but it's on if
it's not right you can reset it okay now
try one this is so poorly put together
why won't it let you just reset the
puzzle I don't know maybe if I overdo it
then it'll work out try that yeah I
can't even I can't even ruin it
that's a way dude - now - or one okay -
two
Oh are there reefs which one raises the
right a lot Hey reset two and one right
now how do you want so where's puzzle
I've ever seen and we're too stupid to
do it properly
do B once more okay okay go on
to n1 I'm literally pressing buttons and
I'm really disappointed - two - now
that's maybe too much now reset that
reset now
wait which one goes up if you [ __ ]
wrote them down we already know what
they do is attribute striving
recepy na this is just like the worst
troll I've ever seen if this is what
you're doing cuz I'm like over it too
all right three this isn't how it works
just pushing things now do you want okay
well I don't they let you reset it okay
[ __ ] it up I have actually been trying
to [ __ ] it up I actually can't I don't
even know how to [ __ ] it up I do too as
well they're just all on now okay try
reset that reset that do one
and then three and then a
ah I'm so happy that was so stupid why
wouldn't they let you just reset it and
start from the beginning so it makes
more sense and I were I'm actually upset
about it all right it would be hilarious
if those things came out of the cases
dude if I [ __ ] die I would actually
lose it and we have to combine those why
do you still have them I don't know I
don't know Oh
okay so should I combine them sure I
think it'd be a little more complicated
than just putting them together if he
were Carlos but whatever cool okay so
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
I knew it goddamn it I knew it
[ __ ] maybe they wouldn't oh my freaking
heart okay wait so
[ __ ] I'm on caution should I eat a plant
yeah save when when you get to the saver
okay got it got it all right
okay straight to Carlos is right go
great
okay we got it misread than that I think
I I think I glad those things aren't
after me mm-hmm shaft type em was there
stuff in here I can't remember if I left
things to kill me later or not all right
go all the way through the hallway
you got this girlfriend stars
oh right yes okay floor one
[Music]
crap okay I hit the wrong button
do I have my machine gun out or not I'm
pretty sure that you can fight the
nemesis coming up and then make it
easier for Jill later on it's really
which I guess I would recommend because
well then I want that might be the end
of the episode and I should save but
I'll yeah yeah yeah you want to save
Jill's items more than anything else
ray I understand nobody care about
Carlos all right it's on
okay wasn't you bad um it would have
been nice if I didn't have to use my
machine gun so much all right
cool well making progress gonna save
Jill give her the vaccine and then win
the game on the penalty so notes to this
go to the park is Jill episode I heal
Jill let's hope you do I'll do it I'll
fix it
it'll be fine
I'm gonna save the day I highly doubt it
save the day